the handle of the hammer is being pushed
up this way that's bending the ruler and
it's forcing this end of the ruler down
onto the table and again it's a pretty
stable system so today I want to talk
about a pretty basic idea in physics and
that's the idea of vectors now I guess
mathematicians might try to steal
vectors from us but but they are a tool
that we use and and they help us
understand some of the physical concepts
that go on behind physics now the idea
is pretty simple a vector is something
that has a size and it has a direction
so the symbol that I'm going to use is
an arrow so we can think about things
that are vector quantities in everyday
life so velocity is one of these vectors
so when you talk about a velocity you
have a size so if I'm traveling in a car
at 30 miles per hour that's this that's
the magnitude or the size of my velocity
but the other important part of it is
the direction so velocity contrasts with
something like speed speed is just the
number speed is just the 30 miles per
hour without the direction so when do we
care about this well let's say you're
driving down the road in your car and
you're traveling at 35 miles per hour
if you encounter a speed trap that speed
trap doesn't care what direction you're
going in they just want to know if
you're above that that magic number 30
miles per hour which is the speed limit
so in that case speed is all that
matters but let's say I'm crossing the
road and I look up and I see a car
traveling at 30 miles per hour I care
very much whether it's going in the
direction towards me or the direction
away from me so aside from
velocity what other vector quantities
might we have well acceleration is one
acceleration has a direction it's just
the change in velocity over time so
another one is force force obviously has
a direction force is just something that
moves a mass moves an object so you can
think of it as a push or pull so if I
push on this book I'm exerting a force
and it's a vector because it has a size
and it has a direction I'm pushing it in
that direction now let's sketch this out
so here's my book roughly speaking so
let's imagine we're both pushing on this
book I'm pushing in this direction and
you're pushing in this direction with
about the same amount of force
well the neat thing about vectors is we
can take those arrows and add them up to
figure out in which direction that book
is actually going to move so let me just
borrow your vector and and and shift it
so it's up here I can then add those
vectors top to tail and the resulting
force is going to be in this direction
so what that says is that if I push this
way and you push that way the book goes
that way it goes straight down the table
we can actually get utens second law so
Newton's second law is very simple it's
F equals MA so it means that the force
is equal to the mass times the
acceleration so what I was just talking
about about a force being something that
accelerates a mass now because I'm
talking about vectors what you might see
in a book is or at least in my notation
which some people call North American is
we we put a little arrow over these
quantities because force and
acceleration are both vectors they both
have a size and they both have a
direction mass doesn't last obviously
doesn't have any direction it's just a
number so if you look in a book
sometimes you might see symbols like
that with arrows and so sometimes if you
look in a textbook you'll see you'll see
this notation or maybe you'll see the
vectors underlined or often you'll see
them in bold pipe
okay so all I'm doing here is tying a
piece of string around this hammer good
length and now I'm gonna use it to
suspend this hammer from this ruler over
the edge of the table what we're doing
here
it's just balancing the ruler and the
hammer and that works pretty well that's
pretty stable right we can actually take
this a little further there you go
so it's not magic it's just physics so
what's happening here well what's
happening is that the sum of all of the
forces on this system is equal to zero
so we've got one force we've got gravity
pulling the head of this hammer down
it's held here by the string so it's
pivoting around that so when this end
goes down this end goes up and that
pushes against this end of the ruler and
what that means is that this end of the
ruler on the table gets pushed down and
so because the center of mass of this
system most of the mass is here
underneath the table because the center
of the mass is right underneath here
the whole system is stable so all of
those forces all of those vectors sum to
zero and we get no acceleration no
change in the movement that's a static
system well so I've talked about these
forces but it's hard to kind of
visualize some of them because this
ruler being wooden is pretty stiff so
we'll do it again but we'll use a
floppier ruler and I have to shorten the
string a little bit okay so now all I'm
doing is I'm switching the type of ruler
that I'm using and I've made the string
a little bit shorter and I probably
can't get it as close to the end of the
table this time but what you can see
very clearly now is you can actually see
that force acting upwards it's bending
this ruler and so the handle of the
hammer is being pushed up this way
that's bending the ruler and it's
forcing this end of the ruler down onto
the table and again it's a pretty stable
system
let me try that again it's a pretty
stable system I can poke it it's gonna
wobble a bit and I'm happy having my
foot underneath because I don't think
it's gonna fall